good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet so
to help you on your journey today's
message is don't dwell on the past over
to you Joe Rogan your life would feel
better and richer if you had a goal you
chased that goal you accomplished some
things and you would get this boost of
confidence you get this boost to
self-esteem like whatever it is that
you're going to do maybe you're in a
drawn comic books maybe you're into it
nah by making pottery or sculptures or
but fine whatever that is and pursue
that instead of doing nothing like the
people that are doing nothing those are
the real people look doing something
might be as simple as like that Alex
Honnold guy he just climbs rocks but
he's world-class rock climber it's
something one of the most common
questions that I get asked when I do
interviews is Evan if you could go back
in a time machine and go talk to your 20
year old self what message would you
give yourself and it's a question that I
always have a hard time answering I
guess it's one of those standard
questions that people like to ask you at
the end of interviews I have a hard time
with that one because I'm so grateful
for where I am right now that I wouldn't
really change anything like everything
that I went through has led me to where
I am right now and I'm happy where I am
right now and so thank you for all those
experiences even though some of them may
been crappy too I don't spend time
thinking about what didn't work and
spend time living in the past and I
think to be an entrepreneur to be
enthusiastic to be optimistic to chase
these dreams that are going forward you
can't do it when you're just stuck in
the past
dwelling on all the mistakes you made
and how much you suck and everything
that went wrong in your life I've had a
lot of negative things that have
happened to me but I don't remember them
I don't focus on them one of the hardest
exercises I had when I first started
working with a media coach was coming up
with my foundation story and thinking
about the hard times I had
my startup business where I was making
the few hundred dollars a month I didn't
remember those stories like all the
negative things that happened to me just
I don't think about them anymore I think
about what I'm focused on the hell where
I'm trying to go and I get how those
stories can help it can help tell the
journey you can help with you guys who
are watching being able to access those
things can help but I don't live there
anywhere close to on a weekly or monthly
you're definitely not a daily basis I
just don't think about negative things
that happen in the past I think you'll
see that consistently with successful
people and then the third answer then
becomes okay well I need to say
something
I don't want to just tell them that
their question you know doesn't really
touch me and so the only thing I come up
with is I would just tell my younger
self to believe more to believe in
myself more to believe in the mission
more to believe that I'm gonna do great
things more to believe that it's gonna
work out more but I wouldn't go and
change any of those specific things that
you know Time Machine might be able to
fix but the time machine doesn't exist
so stop focusing on it right like if the
message is what would I tell a young
person today I love that question but
what would I tell myself from 20 years
ago I can't
I love possibilities I love thinking
about the future and things that are you
know impossible or how to fix that but
this is actually impossible right now
right there's no way to go back and tell
my younger self something so I don't
focus on it
I don't care about it I don't want to go
out and do it if you gave me the option
maybe that's a different choice but just
living in the hypothetical and dwelling
on the past is not interesting to me so
again if I look at this YouTube channel
we've had a lot of failed series I've
had a lot of videos where I really
sucked where my message was okay but my
delivery was really terrible I don't
have a video that I'm least proud of I
don't look at that video and say wow
that that video is really terrible and
it haunts me moving forward I've had a
lot of series that didn't work out you
know we recently cancelled the believe
love series which I loved and I found
really useful but you guys didn't so I
might use that myself personally but not
share it with you there's been tons of
other series though we have a spot in
their calendar that is just for tests
where we're always testing new series
whether you guys agree to them or not
you guys like them you want to share
we've had a series of morning routines
we had a series on favorite books from
entrepreneurs we had a series on yeah we
called it where we like compared to
contrasting points of view and said hey
find the find the line between them and
tons of other series they don't remember
even thinking about the series that we
cancelled I don't even care about it I
can't even access it because I've just
moved on and I don't encourage you to do
the same so many people just live in
their past because one thing didn't work
out once now nothing is ever gonna work
out again you don't have to be the
accumulation of your history you can set
a new path for yourself and so I would
just try to spend as much time as
possible thinking about what you're
doing right now and thinking about where
you want to go and everything gonna
happened happened try to see the
positive it like it lets you to where
you are right now be grateful for those
experiences that guided you to be the
person you are right now with this
vision that you have to move forward and
that's it move forward spend as much as
your mental energy as possible living in
the present and where you want to go and
not dwelling the things that happened to
you because you can't change the past so
the question today today is I'm curious
is there something from your past that
is haunting you and experienced a person
a limiting belief something that is
haunting you and you feel is preventing
you from moving forward with your life
with your business leaving the comments
below
release it let it free let it go so that
you can focus on building something way
more positive I want to see that in the
comments and if you leave a comment
within the first couple hours of this
video going live you make one of our top
two prizes that come out deep I also
want to give a quick shout out to Lazar
yovanovich thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word
really really means a lot to me and I
hope you're enjoying the reading thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
more expresso give me go
well the first time that uh that I
really got involved in UFC was everybody
had seen UFC one you know I saw UFC one
but when we got involved knows because
we started taking jiu-jitsu and through
jiu-jitsu we fell in love with the sport
and then we started to meet some of the
athletes you know when I say we I mean
me and the 42 brothers and it was really
you know learning about the sport and
meeting the athletes that that
completely got us literally addicted to
the sport then when we went to our first
ever UFC event it was uh it was down in
New Orleans at the Uni arena down there
and literally me Franklin runs over
sitting in the audience going holy SH
imagine if they did this and imagine if
they did that this thing could be big
then once we bought it our goal was and
always has been to make this a global
sport go ahead tell me what your vision
board looks like and can you share some
of the things that are on there I just
have a traditional vision board well you
know you would take things that you want
and put them up on poster boy whatever
whatever and that's cool I read you know
I did that when I did the secret but to
me the best vision was when you write
down your long-term and short-term goals
write down everything that you want to
accomplish and keep those things in your
mind because your mind is what makes
them manifest in a reality like your
thoughts really do become things like I
don't have a college degree or anything
like that all I have is back in 1998 I
said I want to be a super jock I said I
want to be one of the biggest radio
personalities on the planet I said I
want to be you know and that Wendy
Williams Tom Joyner Doug banks Howard
Stern you know Bill O'Reilly Rush
Limbaugh I want to be in that number
you know when they think of charlemagne
I want them to think of me like that and
I want to be my generations that because
all of those guys it's the natural
course the thing that power eventually
fades and weakens all of them it's just
like the NBA of music it was the Magic
Johnson Larry Bird era and it was
Michael Jordan era that's LeBron James
era that's just the way things are in
the game and I knew that eventually it
would be my time if I wanted that and so
I claimed it so my vision board is
really just a notebook with everything
that I want
in my life we always had this a goal in
sports and I give the credit to my
coaches for like instilling that in me
is like always creating this goal this
part of time to achieve something and
during that time nothing else mattered
it didn't matter what was happening at
school for me it didn't happen was you
know relationships didn't matter it was
just like retrieving that goal yeah and
maybe comes back to like childhood or
something where I just wanted to be a
great athlete but when I get in that
mind frame I guess I don't know I just
want to achieve the goal more than
anything else and that's that's what I
like to do